if you want a lot of commercial real
estate you may want to skip today's
video because the commercial real estate
industry is getting destroyed for a few
different reasons one in 2019 commercial
real estate was already getting crushed
because we were no longer going to malls
how many malls did we see that were
abandoned I lived in an upscale
community in Dallas Preston Hollow right
across the street was a mall with a
movie theater abandoned massive we're
seeing this across the country why we're
shopping online then covet hits people
are not working from home everybody was
accidentally trained on working on zoom
and people are started saying maybe we
don't need all this office space and
then on top of that then rape spy comes
the way it is right now with interest
rates then banks are getting destroyed
and money's leaving Banks to money
markets so Banks don't have the money to
lend to commercial real estate buyers
and people are sitting there saying what
the hell is going on right now there's a
commercial real estate property in San
Francisco just five years ago it was a
300 million dollar property this is in
the news they're estimating it's going
to sell on an 80 discount from 300
million dollars to 6 60 million dollars
and I'm going to show you a few things
that's going on right now with
commercial real estate again if you're
in this industry watch it at your own
risk I don't know how close to your
following on what's going on with art as
an alternative investment but a lot of
major companies like Goldman Sachs Pimco
they're starting to talk to their
clients about alternative investment
matter of fact this last year I was at
Art basil and guess who was there
Goldman Sachs had a dinner with them and
it was all around people that are
investing millions of dollars into art
as an alternative investment here's some
stats 2022 was the biggest auction year
ever highest total from Victory auction
houses nearly 18 billion dollars so now
you may say Pat that's great I can't
afford to buy five million dollar piece
of art or an 800 000 piece art I don't
have that kind of money you sometimes
talk about baseball cards you bought for
a million dollars I don't have that kind
of money I understand the same way they
created mutual funds a company called
Masterworks allows you to buy into art
by Andy Warhol Pablo Picasso whoever may
be Banksy but you buy shares of that art
so you'll say here's a million dollar
piece I own a share of this art and then
while they sell it you make the return
on that piece of art so today with
what's going on with inflation what's
going on with the economy what's going
on with the stock market people are a
little bit concerned one of the asset
classes people are looking at is
alternative Investments specifically in
art and if you want to participate in
this I highly recommend you look into
Masterworks everything they do is buy
the books SEC you you have to do your
own due diligence while you go through
but if it is something you want to
participate in click on the link below
if you get involved with them it's By
Invitation Only they have 600 000 people
already that are working with
Masterworks and if you want to diversify
your portfolio I highly recommend you
consider Masterworks all right if you
get value from this video give it a
thumbs up and subscribe to the channel
let's get right into it by the way don't
take my word for it I want to share with
you with some other experts from the
industry are saying about what's going
on with commercial real estate here's
what Goldman Sachs thinks about what's
going on in commercial real estate today
lenders with less than 250 billion
dollars and assets account for 80
percent of commercial real estate
lending yet Goldman Sachs in March of
2023 said our economists assume that
small banks with low share of FDIC
covered deposits reduce new lending by
40 percent new lending reduced by 40 so
imagine people are trying to sell buyers
cannot get financed I get a call from a
building at 89 million dollars they
dropped the price two years ago to 56
million dollars to 46 million dollars
then they're about to sell then the guy
that was trying to buy it Silicon Valley
Bank happens he calls me says I can't
get financing can you come in 40 on the
deal with me and I'm not going 40 on the
deal with them because they can't get
financing today because banks are not
financing today that's Goldman Sachs let
me share with you what Morgan Stanley's
Deanwood are saying about commercial
real estate today they believe prices
could fall as much as 40 while nearly
1.5 trillion dollars and that is due for
repayment by the end of 2025. here's
what John kirschner the head of U.S
securitized products that Janice
Henderson investor said he says what
we're doing is being patient staying
away from all but obvious trades and
then just waiting for the distress to
come to us because it will happen
meaning they're going to come to them
saying hey can you please buy this
building from us on 20 cents on a dollar
30 cents on a dollar 40 cents on a
dollar and even Charlie Munger believes
commercial real estate market is in
trouble today so these are not regular
people we're talking about by the way
look at CBRE they're in the commercial
real estate business look at the chart
they're showing right now on what's
going on with commercial real estate
this is a vacancy rate on downtown
offices from 2007 to 2022. you see that
number right there it is up at 17.6
percent the last three months of 2022 it
is the highest it's been since 2007 it's
including 2008 and 2009. look at the
peak of 2010 versus today that was 13.8
percent it's at
17.6 since 2021 office loans in
delinquency have increased ready 44
that's a big number and by the way this
problem even worse in big cities New
York Chicago San Francisco big cities in
California it's even worse matter of
fact Brookfield that is a half a
trillion dollar company they have money
this company just bought one of the
insurance companies I do business with
for roughly four billion dollars here's
what they did they are the largest
office owner in downtown L.A and they
recently chose to default on loans on
two buildings rather than refinance the
debt due to weak demand for office space
to have a trillion other company a lot
of money a lot of assets they choose to
default they don't want to refinance
because no one's trying to release more
office space from them on top of that
I'm not I'm not dumping on San Francisco
but obviously bad policies cause people
to leave remember how I showed you that
picture about the 300 million dollar
building in San Francisco that's going
to sell out an 80 discount you ready for
this number 30 of San Francisco's office
space is vacant today ready seven times
the pre-pandemic percentage you see that
chart right there where it was in 2018
to where it's at today people are not
leasing office space in San Francisco
today they're taking a massive hit this
is a reality this is not some gibberish
these are stats so somebody said well
Pat that's San Francisco how about
Nationwide is this really affecting
everything do you know what is the
biggest banking lending drop in the
history of U.S March of 2023. the
previous three were
2001.com bubble 2008 great financial
crisis 2020 covet and then it's now you
know what the dollar amount is a record
104.7 billion dollars in the last two
weeks of March is how much Bank lending
drop banks are not lending because money
market is getting all the money today
and Banks don't have the money enough to
be able to lend the way they were doing
pre they need money and people are
taking the money out of these Bank
especially with what happened with
Silicon Valley Bank and first Republican
all these other places it's even getting
worse so commercial real estate folks
they own those properties I hope you got
a lot of cash and if you have a lot of
cash and you want to go into commercial
real estate the next six 12 months 24
months maybe 30 months is going to be a
pretty good season to get into it and by
the way we got more pages I can give you
more data I think you got the point on
what's going on today here's a reality
of it question Pat are you buying
commercial real estate properties right
now I am I bought two I'm about to buy
another one I'm making an offer on the
fourth one if you are in auctions the
auction one I'm gonna buy on literally
Pennies on the dollar and I'm buying
that one at twenty thirty percent of
what it was actually worth three years
ago and I'm gonna get into it but I'm
doing it because I'm operating I'm not
doing it because I'm leasing it out now
someone said well Pat should I buy some
commercial real estate is it going to be
a good time to buy discounted if there
is one type of commercial real estate
that the value is not moving is
industrial space because warehouses are
needed whether the direction Amazon's
going all these other places are going
to put the stuff online that they're
selling they still need a warehouse so
the warehouse model is not going away
that is not dropping that's actually
kind of going a little higher than the
class A buildings The Business Office
Buildings those are the ones that take
in a big hit even in Fort Lauderdale
there's a couple buildings brand
spanking new beautiful sexy Law Firm
type of buildings empty they can't sell
them because it's expensive and it's
sexy in class A buildings today are not
what they once were before so for you to
want to risk buying it it's got to be on
you I'm not going to give you advice
this has got to be on you if you believe
we are going away from the model of
working and you know brick and mortar
type of buildings then you know what not
to invest in but if you think this is
going to come back and recover and
everybody's going to be needing these
buildings again you're going to have a
great opportunity next 12 24 36 months
to buy some distressed properties okay
if you got value from this video give it
a thumbs up and subscribe to the channel
I got another video I want you to watch
there's about 85 percent of economists
right now according to Wall Street
Journal that are predicting recession to
your Q4 of 2023 or q1 of 2024. if you
want to know my 10 investing rules that
I follow when it comes to recessions
click here to watch that video it's
actually 10 P's I want to take a look at
that either way have a great day
everybody take care bye bye-bye
foreign